push up
lost a leg
when she was two years old
from landmine
[Music]
i thought that i should do something for
her
dr terchai chiriquet is working with the
world's first elephant hospital located
in thailand
since it opened more than 4 000 injured
and sick elephants have been treated
i'm the first one who invented the
artificial leg for the elephant
[Music]
using his knowledge as an orthopedic
surgeon dr tur chai designed mousha's
artificial limb when she was just a baby
accounting for the elephant's weight and
size
as she has grown pressure on the
prosthetic has increased causing it to
break
so a new one is created every few years
this is a challenge for me too every
time we fix it we
improve it
it's more
sturdy
stronger
this you know
in the textbook
sometimes try and early
when she obeys me give her candy
and she know where the candy is
she used her trying to go into the
pocket
i did operation
on her food about 15 years ago
but she remembered me
she liked to come closer to me
she showed a sign of
salute or happy
i think it means
so much for her
she can
lead a normal life as she should be
[Music]
riding a blind horse
that's a little different
but to me it don't make much difference
he's pretty good friend
he just tickled to death and he rode
i think he knows that he's got eyes and
he just jumps up and down and runs and
really likes to go
[Music]
well my name's roderick olson i'm
soldiers grove wisconsin come on i have
always had a few horses matter of fact
quite a few of them
well we got jackson about 21 years ago
about 10 years ago that we noticed that
he was going blind
and as far as we can find out we've
nothing we can do about it
most the old horse dealers or farmers
they used to just get rid of the horse
but i figured i'm going to keep him
i'd like to stick around a while longer
so
if i went blind i hope they keep me
around a while
[Laughter]
[Music]
i didn't figure he was useless
he does everything you want by the feel
of the range
he's a little different riding than a
regular horse
he's careful when he's running you know
he ain't sure where his feet's gonna go
or what the front of him
but he didn't just quit because he got
blind he's trying to do things so he can
take care of himself
he trusts me
to writing
i think he just figures it man i can see
now i got eyes i can do things that i
wanted to do for a long time
he wants to just run
[Music]
he's fun for me to ride
we go all over the hills down the
canyons
in the water everywhere than any other
horse can go
he does just fine
he must trust me and well i trust him
oh he's kind of a buddy anyhow
being friends with a horse that's a
i don't know that's the way it's been
with me all my life
[Music]
ship ship sheep hi guys hi bubbles hi
walter hi dally hey mama hi baby hi alby
one two three
jenny's farm didn't start out with
animals that were missing limbs they
just happened to come to her farm and
she felt well prosthetic technology has
helped me it could certainly help them
[Music]
i can't imagine not having an artificial
leg because i lost my leg at 10 and i'm
quite used to it it's thanks to medical
science that i'm able to live this
normal life and for these animals i want
no different for them hi felix what goes
on at woodstock farm sanctuary on a
daily basis we're home to right now
around 300 rescued farm animals they've
all come from bad places and they get
the veterinary care the health care that
they need on a daily basis
[Laughter]
she's feisty
can you come help me with felix they're
all actually in the front pasture
little felix came to us as a baby lamb
and he had come from a big sheep farm
and overnight some sort of predator had
gotten in and they found little felix
with
um his leg chewed off
and so i spoke to my prosthetist the
gentleman who makes my legs eric
i don't know if many clinicians would
have went out to the farm i don't have
any experience with fitting prosthetics
on animals very few people in the
country do
so i figured if i could take what
knowledge that i do have and apply it to
the animal i could probably get them to
utilize a prosthesis
and it wasn't until we got hooked up
with suny new pulse and their 3d
printing lab that we were able to make
something pretty cool and cutting edge
for him
seeing him walk on the leg was
absolutely amazing from my limited
interactions with him he isn't
necessarily the most outgoing sheep in
the world he's actually very sheepish
but what he ended up doing was he
started running away from us which was
amazing
we were just jumping for joy that he
could actually get up and run keep up
with his flock
he looked like he was a very happy sheep
if we could do this more
on other animals we wouldn't have to you
know put them down most of the world
doesn't fully understand it they think
of them as just farmed animals but we
hope that that changes
and that's part of the magic of what we
do here they get
pastures to roam in access to the sun
and to the grass
they live life the way they were
intended to live
there's no greater joy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in chennai india there's a tiny camera
repair shop run by a man named joseph
sakhar
and
because every day he feeds thousands of
hungry parakeets on the roof of his home
[Music]
the 2006 tsunami that hit southeast asia
flooded parts of india and displaced
thousands of birds seikar noticed a pair
of parakeets outside of his home and set
some rice out for them
then more started to show up
and well
on the floor
feeding eight thousand parakeets twice a
day is a great expense
cecar spends about forty percent of the
money he makes from repairing cameras
buying food for the birds
[Music]
but for the birdman of chennai there's
more to life than money
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the difference between orangutans and
other animals they need this process of
learning
they learn by imitating they learn by
observing
so that's why we create these
forest schools where they can learn from
each other
[Music]
this is the international animal rescue
center for languages in catapan
we have now 102 orangutans
we come across orangutans that are
kept as pets illegally we're also
rescuing them from the habitat that is
disappearing
when we rescue languidance especially
when they are small babies these babies
have lost their mothers
normally an orangutan will remain with
its mother for as long as seven to eight
years of their lives and this is the
process when the orangutans have the
chance to learn from their mothers how
to survive in the wild what to eat what
not to eat what are the dangers of the
forest what we have to do is to teach
them how to survive in the wild
in these forest schools one of the first
ones is how to be off the ground how to
spend time on the top of the trees which
it might seem like a very simple thing
but actually some of these orangutans
that have been living with people and
having chained up or living in small
cages at the beginning they are afraid
to climb a tree
the ultimate goal of this rehabilitation
is release these animals back to the
wild
what is special with orangutans is they
are very similar to humans
if we
don't care about orangutans
i think it's even more difficult that we
are going to care about any of the other
species
if they get extinct in indonesia they
will be extinct from the face of the
world
so we have to do something about this
now
[Music]